MALE SPEAKER: --to another
round of investing talks.
Today we have a very, very
special guest with us.
So if you've ever tried to ask
people about recommendations
on how to learn about
Warren Buffett's thought
about investing,
thoughts about investing,
chances are that you've come
across two resources most
often.
Of course his annual
letters to the shareholders.
But the other resource
that comes up most often
is "The Essays of
Warren Buffett," which
have been edited and
compiled and published
by none other than our guest
today, Larry Cunningham.
He is also the author of this
new upcoming book, "Berkshire
Beyond Buffett," and I'm just
going to read a couple of lines
from the foreword written
by the legendary Tom Murphy.
"From afar it may
look like Berkshire's
wide-ranging businesses are
very different from one another.
In fact, as Larry's
book discusses,
though they span industries
different from one another,
they are united by
certain key values,
like managerial autonomy,
entrepreneurship, frugality,
and integrity.
This is not happenstance."
And to tell us more,
Larry Cunningham.
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY CUNNINGHAM:
Thank you very much.
It's great to be here at
Google's physical campus.
Having used its virtual assets
for many years in my research,
including for this book,
"Berkshire Beyond Buffett."
And I'm grateful
for the opportunity
to discuss the book here with
you as part of the book tour.
I'm Stopping mostly
at universities
across the country, but it's
fitting to stop at Google
as well, since it is in a
way a center of learning.
You can find more
about the book tour
and see if I'll be
at a campus near you
at the book's website,
berkshirebeyondbuffet.com.
I've been studying
Berkshire for 20 years
and began writing
about it in 1997,
with the publication of the
essays of Warren Buffett.
That grew out of a conference
I organized where I first
met Warren, Berkshire's chairman
and CEO, who participated
alongside his wife, Susan,
and Berkshire's vice
chairman Charlie Munger.
Back then, Berkshire Hathaway
looked like a mutual fund,
primarily owning stocks.
And Warren Buffett was most
famous as a stock picker.
In earlier times, 80%
of Berkshire's value
was in common stocks and only
20% in operational businesses.
Today, the mix is
the other way around.
80% of Berkshire's value is in
its 50 operating subsidiaries
and only 20% in common stocks.
Berkshire is today America's
fifth largest corporation.
Marking its fiftieth anniversary
under Warren's leadership
next year, it is a microcosm
of corporate America.
And its management
principles are
as impressive as Buffett's
investment acumen,
though they are far
less appreciated.
And now that Buffett
is 54, however, people
wonder what will happen to
Berkshire when he's gone.
Is there something so
special about Buffett
that his departure will
spell Berkshire's demise?
Most people think that there is.
"The New York Times" last
year portrayed Buffett
as having a, quote,
"irreplaceable magic touch."
"The Economist"
this year lamented
that Berkshire was
down to, quote,
"playing out the last hand."
Such views are paradoxical.
Buffett's goal has been to
build a lasting corporation.
And yet, even fans like these
think the company cannot
survive without him.
So I researched
this question and I
found the inverse to be true.
That there's something so
special about Berkshire
that it can prosper even
without Warren Buffett.
I conclude that Buffett's
greatest single achievement,
more than vast fortune
and generous philanthropy,
is creating an organization
larger than himself.
True, Buffett may
epitomize Berkshire,
but it is far from
a one-man show.
First, there is a
deep managerial bench,
dozens of outstanding executives
who helped build Berkshire.
For my research, Buffett gave
permission for them to help me.
And they did, many of them
through interviews, surveys,
and some even commented
on the manuscript.
A dozen are joining
me on the book tour.
It's an impressive
group of people.
A second group are
Berkshire's directors,
many who also helped me, like
former Microsoft executive
Charlotte Guyman, Warren's
son, Howard, and especially
Tom Murphy, who built Capital
Cities ABC into a media
powerhouse.
Earlier this year at
Berkshire's annual meeting,
I asked Warren who should
write the forward to the book.
He instantly said Tom Murphy.
I asked why.
He said, Tom was his
role model as a manager.
Warren said he'd
learned most of what
he knows about
management from Tom.
These comments are
noteworthy because this book
is the first about Buffett
as a manager, not as just
an investor, and the
first about Berkshire
as a corporate entity, not just
a portfolio of investments.
And Tom's foreword, which
was read to you a moment ago,
captures an important
theme of the book
and I've just put the same quote
you just heard on the screen.
"Most of what I've
learned about management,"
Warren said, "I
learned from Murph.
I kick myself
because I should have
applied the lessons
much earlier."
Here's Tom's quote,
"From afar, it
looks like
Berkshire's businesses
are very different
from each other.
But on close inspection, they're
united by cultural bonds."
This is the myopia that
commentators suffer from.
They concentrate
and overemphasize
the diversity of the
businesses and underappreciate
and sometimes overlook
the cultural unity.
Berkshire subsidiaries
engage in a wide range
of totally unrelated businesses,
insurance and paint, energy
and housing, transportation
and food, jewelry
and pig-feeding equipment.
They vary in size from fewer
than 1,000 employees at many,
like Ben Bridge Jeweler,
to more than 30,000
at Fruit of the Loom.
Annual revenues run between
300 million and one billion
for most, and there are
eight whose revenues
are so large that
if stood alone,
they'd be Fortune 500 companies.
Profit margins are all over
the place, stretching from 1%
at McLane, the logistics
supply chain manager,
to 25% at BNSF Railway.
Berkshire subsidiaries
were acquired at prices
all over the map, way less than
a billion for Justin boots,
2 billion for Shaw carpets, 9
billion for the Marmom group,
the conglomerate that Jay
and Robert Pritzker built.
They were acquired
at varying multiples,
from cheap bargains for
the maker of Garanimals
to princely premiums for
the likes of BH Energy.
And Berkshire subsidiaries are
headquartered all over the map.
Beneath that slide is a map of
the United States of America
that in this picture
are not showing up,
but they are in Massachusetts,
North Carolina, Tennessee,
California,
Washington, all over,
more than half the
states of the country.
This diversity can be
explained by the first sentence
of my book.
Berkshire Hathaway
is an accident.
It has never had
a business plan.
It doesn't believe
in strategic plans.
It is purely opportunistic,
buying companies
that fit its criteria
and gel with its culture.
Berkshire has
disclosed what it seeks
in its acquisitions since 1986,
when it ran an ad in the "Wall
Street Journal"
stating its criteria.
Those criteria
have never changed,
except for size, which went from
5 million in annual earnings
back then to 75 million today.
Proven profitability, good
unleveraged returns on equity,
management in place, basic
businesses, and a fair price.
Berkshire often sites
Berkshire culture
as part of what will enable
it to prosper without him,
but he's never said
exactly what that culture
is or explained
where it comes from.
That's where I come in.
By defining and illustrating
Berkshire culture,
my book contends
that this culture
is Berkshire's most valuable and
durable competitive advantage,
which will contribute to
its business longevity
long after the
Warren Buffett era.
Intuitively, people don't
expect conglomerates,
vast and diverse, to have
discernible corporate cultures,
but Berkshire has
a distinctive one,
based on a core set
of shared values.
In my research, I
probed Berkshire's
fifty main subsidiaries,
seeking to identify
their corporate cultures,
looking at the practices
and beliefs that define
them, through legends, lore,
and the trials of transitions.
I then scrutinized
these profiles,
and as I did a pattern emerged.
I saw recurring traits across
all of them, nine altogether,
all being intangible traits
that the subsidiaries
turn into economic gain.
In the book, by offering
individual snapshots
of these fifty companies,
organized around those nine
values, the book presents
a portrait of the whole.
Let me highlight a
few of these traits.
Berkshire subs
tend to be thrifty,
some say frugal,
cheap, even tightwads.
Geico is a great example.
Its business model
is to be the low cost
supplier of car insurance,
a standardized product
that law requires people
to have and few people
wish to splurge on.
Geico turns those conditions
into a competitive advantage.
It doesn't pocket all the
savings from its thrift,
but passes most on to customers.
In fact, it caps it's
underwriting profit at 4%.
If profits would
be more than that,
it lowers prices, delivering
value to its customers.
This, of course,
is not altruism.
That model grows market share,
increases total premiums,
and enlarges aggregate profits.
All Berkshire subsidiaries
embrace the golden rule.
Do unto others as you would
have them do unto you.
Take Clayton Homes.
It is a leading lender
to lower-income families
in the United States and also
manufactures the trailer homes
that many of that cohort buy.
It always looks out
for its customers.
Here's an example of
how Jim Clayton, who
founded the company,
treated his customers.
He sat down with
them and determined
what their income was
and their resources,
and then worked
backwards to build homes
and lend money to
meet their budgets.
Integrity like this pays.
Amid the financial
crisis of 2008,
Clayton's peers were
uncovered lending
to sketchy buyers who they lured
in with low teaser interest
rates.
Those companies faltered
and many cratered
during the financial crisis.
That enabled Clayton
to prosper, moving it
from fourth in its
industry to number one.
Integrity is so
central at Berkshire,
that managers even remotely
threatening it are soon let go.
Whether David Sokol,
once considered
a probable successor
to Buffett, who
was alleged to have
engaged in insider trading,
or successive managers at
Benjamin Moore, who prepared
to market paint through
big box retailers
in violation of a
commitment Berkshire
had made to its local
distributor network.
Berkshire subs are earnest.
They consider keeping a
promise to be sacrosanct.
And they turn that moral
conviction into economic gain.
Examples are Berkshire's other
two big insurance companies,
National Indemnity,
NICO, and Gen Re.
They insure large and unusual
risks, some spanning decades.
These features render their
word in insurance policy
a precious asset.
For instance earlier
this year, NICO
insured an offer by
Quicken to pay $1 billion
to anyone correctly predicting
the Men's NCAA 64 Tournament
Bracket, the odds of
which are something
like 1 in 126 billion.
If you pick it, Quicken
probably doesn't
have the billion dollars
to pay, but NICO does
and it will pay up.
The NICO, Gen Re business
model differs from Geico's.
They don't put the money in
the pockets of customers.
They pocket the profit.
They charge premiums for the
kind of special commitments
that these high-end
products entail.
So Berkshire thus
generates value
from its high-end
businesses where
customers pay a premium
for earnestness.
People prize autonomy
and complex businesses
gain value from
hands-off oversight.
Berkshire is thoroughly
decentralized,
with subsidiary CEOs having
virtually unbridled discretion
over all operational
and strategic decisions.
Autonomy starts at the
top and trickles down
throughout the subsidiaries
and in most subsidiaries,
it tends to trickle
down across that.
A conspicuous example
is The Pampered Chef,
which sells its kitchen
gadgetry through 70,000
independent distributors, all
of whom call their own shots.
Every CEO I interviewed
for the book
emphasized the value of
autonomy at Berkshire.
Jim Weber, the CEO of Brooks,
the running shoe company,
put it this way in my
interview with him.
Quote, "I've never had so
much autonomy in my career
and never felt so accountable."
Tom Manenti, the CEO of MiTek,
the construction material firm,
spoke of the trickle down
rationale in my interview
with him.
Quote, "Berkshire and Buffett
give me total autonomy.
Being treated that
way makes it easy
for me to treat our
managers the same way."
In chapter 16, I conclude
with this sentence, quote,
"Berkshire's secret to
managing a large complicated
organization is to
manage parsimoniously,
as little as possible.''
And finally Buffett is well
known as a long-term investor.
But a more profound point
about time at Berkshire
is that its horizon is forever.
Unique among its arrivals
in the acquisition market,
Berkshire has not sold a
subsidiary in 40 years.
That sense of permanence
has great economic value,
whether to family
businesses wanting a legacy
or entrepreneurs
wanting security.
The most dramatic
are subsidiaries
I call corporate orphans,
those that were owned serially
by leveraged buyout
operators, private equity
firms, or bankruptcy trustees.
The experience can make managers
ache for a permanent home.
For example, the
recreational vehicle maker
now called Forest River was
owned by three different LBO
operators in a row
before being acquired
by its current CEO, Pete Liegl.
It raised funds in yet another
LBO, borrowed very costly debt,
the LBO operators micromanaged
Pete and the company
soon sailed into bankruptcy.
Pete bought most of the
assets out of bankruptcy,
rebuilt the company,
positioned it as number one
in the industry, and then
sold it to Berkshire,
where he continues to
expand, without debt,
with total autonomy,
and a permanent home.
So permanence is
Berkshire's bedrock.
That is reason to believe
in Berkshire's future
after Warren Buffett is gone.
Now, the Warren Buffett
era continues of course,
and may continue for
another decade or two,
as Warren is in
very good health.
Still, whenever it ends, as
I write in the book's closing
passages, quote, "while it's
hard to imagine Berkshire
without Buffett, it seems
wiser to believe in Berkshire
beyond Buffett, an institution
that transcends the man
and will be his legacy."
I thank you very much
for your attention.
I'd be delighted to have
questions from the audience.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I know that,
at least in the past,
Warren Buffett
has kind of tended
to avoid tech companies in his
investments, kind of saying he
doesn't understand the industry,
it's under a lot of change.
Do you foresee that changing in
the Berkshire beyond Buffett?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: It
might change a little.
I mean, the lack
of understanding
is a relatively personal
quality that Buffett has.
And so if his successor were
more tech savvy and able
to understand it,
there's great possibility
that you would see some tech
companies within the Berkshire
family.
The piece about
rapidity of change,
though, is a question mark.
Berkshire prefers
rudimentary businesses,
those that have been
around a long time, that
change relatively little.
And so if the successor
were to adhere
to that aspect of
the rationale, I
wouldn't expect to see a great
many come into the Berkshire
fold.
So we'll have to see.
But certainly, the
first half, somewhat
of an idiosyncratic
position rather
than an institutional position.
But the need for focusing
on rudimentary businesses,
I think, will provide
a continuing filter.
AUDIENCE: As you
were closing this,
you mentioned there was that
person who did the homes
and then sold it.
It came out of LBO three
times, and then they
ended up selling it.
Yeah, that one-- Forest River.
So after he made a profit,
what was the benefit
of going to
Berkshire after that?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: Capital.
In order to grow
this company, it's
a capital-intensive operation.
It's a manufacturing operation.
He's got plants in a variety of
states, distribution centers,
and so on.
And so in order to
grow, he needed capital.
And his personal
experience with the LBO,
and the company's experience
with LBOs before him
showed that borrowing
large amounts of capital
can be dangerous.
So he did not want to go the
LBO route to get capital.
I left out that-- I tell
in the book-- he had also
taken the company
public at one point
to gain capital, which also
provided a bit of a bruising
experience.
Short-term pressure to
deliver profits this quarter,
and this half year,
and so on, were
difficult to sustain in
the recreational vehicle
manufacturing space.
So this LP, he had just been
bruised-- borrowing money,
raising equity in the
public capital markets.
So once he righted the ship,
he needed more capital.
And Berkshire was a
perfect place for him.
Because there's
plenty of capital,
and as long as you're generating
good returns on capital,
you're likely to
get plenty more.
And he has done a terrific
job in doing that.
In his press release, when he
announced that transaction,
emphasized that this
company will no longer
be borrowing money.
So it's all Berkshire
capital, and he's just
doing a phenomenal job.
And he's just one example.
There are seven what I
call corporate orphans
that I feature in that chapter.
They pivot around that
same longing for a way
to generate capital
without the shackles
of either micromanagement
or short term-ism.
Berkshire is one place.
AUDIENCE: Recently, Berkshire
made some big investments
in BYD in China and
Posco in South Korea.
I was wondering, on a
going-forward basis,
do you see more of that?
And since culture is such
a big part of the business,
how do they evaluate
the management
with such different
cultural situations?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM:
Excellent question.
Thanks.
I would first draw a
distinction between common stock
investments like those two that
you mentioned, where Berkshire
buys a minority
interest and doesn't
have the full control
over those enterprises,
and on the other
hand, the subsidiaries
that it does fully
own and fully control.
So the commitment of permanence
is to those companies
that it fully controls
and fully owns.
So when it bought See's Candy,
or Forest River, or Geico,
the commitment
is, we will always
own you and never sell you.
You with me?
So those minority common
stock positions, Berkshire
and Buffett would prefer
to own them forever,
but there's no
commitment of that sort.
So if they deteriorate
economically,
culturally, or for other
reasons, they're sold.
And that explains
the subsidiaries.
All but one are American
companies based in America
with managerial
affinity to things
Berkshire has been doing for
a long time and understands.
The one exception is ISCAR,
short for Israeli Car Buy,
which is based in Israel with
operations all over the world.
And it's actually-- even
though it's a foreign company,
it has a lot in
common with Berkshire.
It's a large conglomerate, a
network of different companies.
But when they went
and bought that,
it was a very slow
transaction for Berkshire.
Because he, Buffett,
and his inner circle
had to learn about Israel,
management practice there,
tax issues.
So it took a lot longer.
So with that backdrop,
I don't expect
many immediate additional
acquisitions abroad.
But I do predict in the book
that we will see that gradually
in the coming years.
But I think, in other words,
that the Berkshire model
is scalable to the world.
But I think it will take longer
to do that than it has taken
to spread across
the United States.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
One of my concerns
for Berkshire is
that what if the successor
engages in empire building?
So if they make some big,
major mistake in acquisition,
then Berkshire is going to
underperform the [INAUDIBLE].
So what's your take on that?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM:
Yeah, I think so.
I think the first thing to
appreciate about mistakes
is that Berkshire has made a
lot of them in its history.
And the first thing that the
successor and his community
will need to remember
is that they're
going to make them again.
You with me?
People should avoid-- I think
the one big risk for Berkshire
beyond Buffett is the nostalgia
trap, when people think, oh,
Berkshire was so
wonderful before.
Now there are
mistakes being made.
So mistakes will be made.
And I think people should
accept that the CEO will
make mistakes.
If the mistake
she or he makes is
a mistake of violating
traditional Berkshire culture,
undermining some of
these principles,
then I think there would be
serious cause for concern.
For example, if a
successor were to say,
we are not going to continue
to own Forest River.
We've had enough of it.
We're going to sell it.
If they did that, that's
more than a mistake.
That would be a breach, I
think, of Berkshire culture.
And if that kind of
decision were made,
the CEO began selling
off subsidiaries,
that would destroy Berkshire,
it would undermine, at least,
a very important
fundamental principle.
I don't think a
person will do that.
There may be some pressure.
Activist shareholders
might pressure a successor
to sell this company, that
company, or the other one
to get the cash rather than
having these companies sit
inside the broad conglomerate.
I don't think the activist
shareholders will succeed
in that kind of
campaign, however,
because all the CEOs
of Berkshire companies
understand these
values, buy into them,
and one of them who's leading
the company will sustain them.
Moreover, the board
of directors that I
refer to understand
these values,
appreciate their
importance, and will likely
try to enforce them.
Indeed, the chairman
of the board
is very likely be
Warren's son Howard,
whose job, Warren
has said, will be
to remind everyone, if
needed, of Berkshire culture.
So there is some risk there.
But I think the
plan that's in place
is the best reasonably possible
plan to protect against it.
AUDIENCE: I have a
three-part question.
Given that the success of
Berkshire going forward
is mostly the operational
companies and not
the investments, what do
you think the investment
portfolio plays a
role going forward,
specifically Ted and
Todd's role going forward?
How important will it be?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: OK.
Shall I take that one first?
That's great.
I think it's true that in
terms of Berkshire overall,
the investment portfolio is
now 20% of the overall value.
And so within that
broad company,
it's less important
than it's ever been.
I should stress, it's
still $120 billion.
So it's not like you
can just ignore it.
It's a lot of money.
Ted Weschler and Todd Combs
have been successful investors
on their own before
joining Berkshire
five or seven years ago.
They have now continued to
show their investment prowess,
sometimes beating Warren
Buffett in those years.
So I've got a lot of
confidence in those fellas,
and obviously Warren
does and the board does.
I think their job,
the hardest thing
they will have to deal
with is the anchor of size.
It's very difficult with
that amount of money
to pick stocks and continue
to outperform the market.
Moreover, Berkshire's
investment portfolio
is highly concentrated.
Of that $120 billion odd, 70% of
it is in just seven companies--
American Express, Wells Fargo,
IBM, Coca Cola, Exxon Mobile.
Just seven companies make
up 70% of the portfolio.
Now, in the next
5, 10, or 15 years,
the economic characteristics
of one or more of those
may deteriorate.
And it may be time to sell.
Whoever has to make
that decision, that's
a huge challenge to decide,
OK, we're selling Coca Cola.
That's going to be a very
hard decision to make.
Moreover, having
made it, then they
have to figure out what to do
with $10, $15, or $20 billion
in one fell swoop.
It's very rare to find
acquisition opportunities
of that scale, as
Berkshire repeatedly shows.
It's eager to find such
things, but they simply
don't come up very often.
So Todd, Ted, or
whomever is running
that portfolio is going to have
a very hard job of deciding
what to do.
Probably, it will
mean buying a larger
number of smaller stakes.
In other words, making it look
more and more like the market.
I think Todd and Ted,
they will do fine.
But it's going to be a very
different job than the job
Warren has had,
and there are going
to be some heavy challenges.
AUDIENCE: I think part of
the question is answered,
but I'll ask it anyway.
How do you compare Ted and
Todd's performance so far
to, say, Warren Buffett's
investing prowess about 20,
25 years ago?
I think both of
them are managing,
what, $7 or $10
billion together?
I'm thinking if you went
back to '70s or '80s
when Warren was
managing that portfolio.
How do you compare the two?
Do you have any insights
or additional thoughts?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: They
are experienced investors
with a good track record.
At Berkshire,
they, I think, were
responsible for
selecting DirecTV,
which had a good run
and then a big payout,
and also for DaVita
Health, which
is developing kidney
dialysis equipment.
And both of them
are very successful.
So it's hard to compare,
are those like Coca Cola,
or like Cap Cities ABC?
I don't know.
It's different eras, it's
different types of businesses
and so on.
But the track record is strong.
There's a joke floating
around on Twitter this morning
about this person is the
Warren Buffett of Canada,
and this person is the
Warren Buffett of China,
Warren Buffett of Australia.
And someone from MarketWatch
asked me, is it good to say,
you're the Warren
Buffett from this place,
and that place, and
the other place?
And my response,
thanks to my wife,
was there's only
one Warren Buffett.
As good as Tad and Ted
are, they're not Warren,and
they're not going to be Warren.
But I think they'll do
just fine for themselves.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think about this idea
that software is
eating the world,
and that basically,
a lot of businesses
that have been sort of immune to
technological change for a time
basically get more
and more software
that will determine their
eventual profit margin?
When I look at the
list of the companies,
they seem the ones that are a
little bit insulated, maybe,
right now.
But down the road, do you
think that's going to change?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM:
Every competitor
faces risks of
technological change,
and disruption, and
even obsolescence.
That's been true
throughout history.
And we probably are
living in a period
of particularly rapid change.
Even companies in
Berkshire's family face this.
And See's Candies, for example,
is an excellent confectioner
with a terrific
product and brand name,
but it's been kind of regional.
And they have not been able to
expand it despite the internet.
And they need to.
And they are working on
that, but it's going slowly.
The Pampered Chef to
which I referred earlier
sells its products
through these 70,000
independent distributors.
Traditionally, these people
have parties at their homes
and invite friends and
neighbors to test out the stuff
and use it.
And it's a quaint, delightful,
wonderful business model
that was very
successful in the '90s,
but is less successful now.
They need to figure
out how to navigate
the current environment.
Berkshire has acquired
a lot of newspapers,
just in the last
three or four years,
a business that is
rapidly changing.
So many Berkshire companies
face this kind of challenge.
What's special about Berkshire
is that it sticks with them
and attempts to help ride out
the onslaught, and adapt to it,
and change, and evolve,
rather than just sell it.
So as long as other
members of the family
maintain their
competitive advantages
and generate capital to
support those that need it,
the whole can be sustained.
And the idea of keeping even
those that are struggling
is so fundamental to the
company's DNA and its success
that anybody who takes over the
CEO job will have to see that.
AUDIENCE: So during
the financial crisis,
AIG was destroyed just because
a small part of the company.
It was the derivative
department.
So do you see that
there might be
something like
that in Berkshire?
Some major mistake
that just destroys
all of the shareholder value?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: Right.
Yeah, that's right.
It was the Financial
Products Division at AIG
that had expanded a portfolio
of credit default swaps
that turned out to be toxic.
And Ben Bernanke, the Chairman
of the Federal Reserve
at the time,
described the company
as being an insurance company
with a hedge fund on top.
That FP division had absorbed
enormous risks and became,
really, a cancer that
threatened to metastasise
across the company
until the great surgeons
at the federal government
did serious surgery
and saved the victim
in a certain way.
I wrote a book about that
with the former chairman
of the company
and attribute that
to a problem of internal
control with the company,
that that group should not
have been able to do that.
There should have been
monitoring and oversight
of that group that had
simply disappeared.
So it's a great and
important question.
Every company needs
to have some mechanism
to identify potential
rogues in their midst
to eliminate that
kind of problem.
And I do think
Berkshire has that.
It's not a traditional
internal control structure
with lots of layers
of oversight,
and thick reporting protocols,
and second guessing its own
that you would see today at
AIG, or at IBM, or probably
even at Google.
But instead, this
approach-- what
I call a trust-based approach
to corporate governance--
relies heavily on that
autonomy principle.
So at Berkshire headquarters,
there is no direct mechanism
to monitor, let's say, the
Cyprus Insurance Company.
What exactly are
they underwriting?
Or even, for that
matter, Gen Re.
Gen Re got into
considerable difficulty
shortly after Berkshire
acquired it in the late '90s
because it had underwritten
a concentrated level
of super catastrophic risk
of biological, chemical,
and nuclear disaster.
And after 9/11, it
faced insolvency.
And if Berkshire hadn't acquired
it a couple years before,
it would have gone under.
Berkshire put into
place senior management
who vowed to correct
that problem,
eliminate those kinds
of concentrated risk,
and maintain a culture
in which that will not
be permitted to happen again.
So all across Berkshire,
that kind of autonomy, trust
is baked into the company.
A rogue can show up anywhere.
But I think-- I am convinced
that the governance,
the control model at Berkshire,
this trust-based model,
does work at the company.
So I have a very
low level of concern
that you would see
a financial products
division like AIG
had at Berkshire.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the importance of culture
in the companies that
Berkshire acquires.
Does Berkshire
look for companies
that already bring the
same cultural values to it,
or do the subsidiaries
evolve to that same point?
And how does a large
company like Berkshire
preserve its culture?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: That's
an excellent question.
My answer is that
it's iterative.
When Berkshire scouts
for acquisitions,
or when acquisition proposals
are presented to it, primarily
to Warren, he has a sense
that the company needs
to be frugal, earnest,
entrepreneurial,
prepared for autonomy, and
interested in the long term.
So it's a mental checklist
that he has that companies that
fit the Berkshire
mold will also have.
Then when they join
the Berkshire family,
those values get reinforced.
And so the family is, in
that way, self-sustaining.
Then that is sui
generis in the sense
of being almost automatic.
Sure, people need to
buy into the principles
and need to reinforce
them through their words
and actions.
But I think you see
that in abundance.
But it could unravel if the
wrong leadership assumed
control and decided that these
values were not important
anymore, and began to
micromanage the CEOs,
to sell subsidiaries,
or to skate
close to the edge of integrity,
and so on, then the culture
could unwind.
And you'd have simply
another conglomerate
like Litton Industries, or
Gulf and Western, or United
Technologies, or General
Electric, what have you.
And what is special about
Berkshire would dissolve.
AUDIENCE: You've written
about Ben Graham, the essays
of Warren Buffett, and
then AIG in this book.
Through all your years of
interacting with everyone,
what would you say is one thing
you learned that you would like
to share with us about
investing, and then one thing
that you learned that could
apply to just life in general?
LARRY CUNNINGHAM: I'll
take the second one first,
because it's easier.
It's integrity.
Life in general-- just being
honest, being forthright,
keeping your word, treating
your promises as sacrosanct,
staying in the middle
of the playing field,
to use an athletic
analogy, avoiding skating
on the edge of thin ice.
I like Buffett's
admonition on this point
that he came up with in the
late 1980s Salomon Brothers bond
trading scandal.
That was an investment banking
firm brought to its knees
by a few rogue traders who tried
to corner the US Treasury bond
market, and it threatened
the life of the firm.
And in trying to rehabilitate
this institution, which
had been a venerable
banking house,
the board asked Warren, who had
bought stock in the company,
to become chairman.
And he stepped into that
role with great turmoil.
And the first thing he did was
clean out the top management
ranks and install three of
his own chosen executives
to be CEO, general
counsel, and CFO.
And these were people
with exemplary reputations
for ethical business leadership.
He then stood up and
told a press gathering,
and wrote a memo to
the workers, that
said, lose money for the firm,
and I will be understanding.
Lose a shred of reputation for
the firm, and I'll be ruthless.
I'm getting chills
just saying that.
Did you get chills?
And his test for that,
in case you needed it,
was in any action you're
about to take-- any insurance
policy you're going to
underwrite, any bond trade
you're going to do, any
leasing transaction, any sale
of a mobile home-- he said,
think about that decision,
your activity, being
written up by a journalist
on the front page-- or now your
web page-- of your hometown
paper by a smart journalist.
Would you do it knowing all
your friends and neighbors
know this is what you did?
That's a pretty good test.
That's my answer to
your second question.
Life lessons to me, lessons I'd
like to share with my children,
integrity is really number one.
I like being thrifty,
and I like autonomy,
and I like permanence.
They're all very important.
But if you had to
boil it down, I
think integrity is number one.
Investing lessons, I
admire the tradition
of value investing
begun by Ben Graham,
sustained by and modified by
the likes of Phil Fisher, who
wrote the great book "Common
Stocks And Uncommon Profits,"
and by Charlie Munger, Warren's
partner since the '70s or '60s,
and Warren himself,
who emphasized
fundamental,
substantive analysis
of particular positions.
It's hard homework.
It's not easy to do.
It requires research and effort.
But I admire that tradition.
So I guess the one thing I
learned from that is investing
is a significant undertaking.
And if you're not
prepared for it, it's OK.
But then the best thing to
do with your personal excess
capital is to buy an index fund,
like the ones run by Vanguard
or Fidelity, so that you don't
really have to do the work.
You enjoy the market return.
Good and bad overall,
long term probably good.
But if you're going to
do tailored investing,
then I like the value
investing model,
fundamental [? substantive ?]
model in comparison, say,
with trying to track patterns
in performance over time,
or trying to time the
market on a daily basis,
getting in and out
at the right times,
and other techniques
that don't appeal to me.
So I've been a great devotee
of that Graham Fisher Buffett
Munger crowd.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
That was fascinating.